[Music]
recession its water measure
juicehead Callao yeah yeah makki madani
timothean combinated into the Volta
module my way he'll I'm too needy I was
born in Baku Azerbaijan my parents are
from a small tribe in Azerbaijan called
Mountain Jews and they emigrated when I
was four from Azerbaijan to Turkey so
for the biggest chunk of my life I grew
up in Istanbul Turkey and had a great
time learned a lot about Turkish culture
I wants to work over summer and one of
the best kind of work opportunities for
people my age who speak some kind of
English was to work as a fortune-teller
for the tourists oh can we have some
coffee yeah yeah yeah no let's yeah good
yeah great
how do we do that okay so first we're
going to take the coffee cup class and
then we're going to cover it with the
saucer okay got it
and then with your tongue at the bottom
and then your index finger middle finger
on the top okay like that not yet and
now you're gonna make a wish we're not
going to tell it okay and keep about
that wish and how much you want this
wish to attend real life okay and while
doing it turn three times okay
okay and then now we're going to very
quickly turn it outward and put it
saucer on the table okay yeah and while
we're doing this I'm gonna say it to
phrase okay basically says whatever is
my situation let that appear in the cup
okay nice the Harlem and fun okay
great now we're going to let it cold a
little bit but before we do that would
you mind putting your ring or a coin
everything indicates that you want to
hear more about personal relationships
romantic relationships friends love sort
of things and coin indicate you want to
know more about your professional goals
money
Megan Helms hmm let's go personal okay
okay so I put it on the Veronica okay
and we believe that the energy of the
Ring and what ring stands for they're
going to actually influence what is
located in the country not only about
the future it's also about what has an
end the path schedules inner truth our
knowledge of what its future going to be
right we'll wait a little bit until it
drives the fortune teller obviously like
all the types of other fortune-telling
training a lot of them you try to read
your customer in a way so like first
what happens what is one of my
instructions in the cafe was the
tourists would come I would ask tourists
a bunch of introductory questions try to
understand whether this person is rich
or poor or married or single where is
this person from and kind of understand
what are the worries in this person's
mind and after you drink the coffee and
try start interpreting the coffee you
kind of project the things you've
learned about this person into the
coffee cup and pretend that it's the
coffee cup that's telling you all those
things that you have learned before yeah
so you really use your interpretation
skills and ways it's almost like
clinical psychology practice right you
are trying to bring it without giving
like
directed advice panels you're trying to
leave them to come to advice they want
to hear by themselves right and they
want to do so I think some of the
fortune tellers would really approach
their work from that one but we also
used to have a booklet and the book was
basically was this was a short like
maybe 10 15 pages for clarity's but
would say like rabbits means that star
means that
I scraper doesn't means the statutes
better so this way when we interpret the
shapes we have kind of a basis a lot of
people have different ways of looking at
the cups inside because now you're going
to see I'm going to divide the cup in
different parts and different parts for
me is going to mean different things
yeah for my cup away okay and I will
return your ring for you thank you the
energy is there I feel and I will select
the cup
the way I look at the cup is always
basically the handle part this part is
about love this part is about wealth
when I cut from the middle the left part
is about going to be present in the past
and then the right part is about going
to be the Box feature okay and the very
dark bottom is going to be about family
some other people that radicals here
also had this discussion about whether
people really really want to know the
future organize I just kind of want to
chat about the future and there maybe
which phase right or made it it's just a
nice opportunity to have a chat so what
was the balance of that kind of goal
with people I think for our culture most
of the time it's the social tool to get
to know other people and catch up with
friends so when you say let's have a cup
of Turkish coffee this means that you're
committing more like a chunk of an hour
and a half two hours to actually sit
down it's not something on the go and
you sit down and really discuss life
matters right let's say like you are
divorcing from someone or you are
changing your career path you're
relocating for one city to another or
your mother is going to an ill kind of
like important events in your life and
you want those events to be you know
discussed the mention is shared with
someone but you also want to know
whether those events are potentially
going to come to a positive or negative
outcome yeah so I think coffee drinking
culture really and the coffee cup
fortune telling really enables that type
of a venue for people to alleviate their
own worries you know how old it is when
it started yes so we know according to
historical records of the Ottoman Empire
that it's around 16th century when the
Ottoman Sultan for the first time kind
of started having this what we call
today's Turkish coffee actually comes
from
Yemen okay and it was important in
doctor hands when basically with a part
of Ottoman Empire and came all the way
to the Sudan and so ii love the taste of
it okay and we know that some of the
people were brought from the city from
istanbul at the time to come to this
whole time and give his fortune from
looking at the cup and kind of that's
how it spread to the elite local elites
of the Ottoman Empire at the time
and from there but onwards to all the
region I see a volcano volcano oh look
at that that really that looks almost
like a pyramid volcano thank you she
does some lava coming actually became in
a very common feature in popping up
fortune-telling really the mountain in a
volcano okay not happens when the tops
is not shot I think and a month in
happens when the top two shots okay
monthly means actually there's going to
be a challenging path and at the end
there's going to be a lot of relief and
a lot of habit volcano means there's a
lot of something coming it's like a
volcano eruption okay that might mean
good things or bad things great but
mostly volcanoes indicates that there's
a lot of energy of some sort that's
coming your way
okay and this volcano gladly has an
opening you see that at the end there's
an open Stephanie
and so this opening would indicate once
again that whether this volcano brings
bad news or good news where there's a
lot of bad things happening or a lot of
good things happening in one moment it
is going to resolve input okay if this
was completely closed which could happen
have happened that was completely cool
that would mean that it's a completely
negative result even if it's a positive
okay no so this would mean nothing to
worry there's going to be a time that's
coming in a new feature and we also know
that coffee cups cannot tell you more
than for today okay like this is in the
next for today is that to ensure the
return of the patron to be coffee coffee
can L agree that I want to see my friend
again it's got it okay in that no border
for today when I was growing up and my
mom was working and I was like I don't
know nine years old ten years old and I
didn't want to stay alone I would go
with my mom to to work and see all these
woman doing these some types of like
fortune-telling a prediction system I go
with the cycle lunar cycle or astrology
but when what's going to happen in
certain Turkish people's lives right and
that was a big part of the local culture
yeah it was a big part of the local
culture and I think there's different
certain individuals who choose to not
engage that right and there's certain
individuals who choose to believe in it
a lot and are very we have a phrase that
says don't ever believe in
fortune-telling fully but never stay
with that fortune-telling hat I need to
like do it a little bit but not too much
if you see there's a bunch of powers
actually could be an Eiffel Tower I am
going on the Eiffel Tower remember I've
never been to France many times a night
of power up any - power and I know how
it is we have the Eiffel Tower is that
we like that exactly look like the
Eiffel Tower and the Eiffel Tower is in
the romantic side Oh like the
relationship is really hair it is really
a student romance Hey for the main
situation of where I see coffee being
drink drinks is like middle-aged
population because they have the biggest
worries I thing in their lives right
about money about love about marriage
about different things yes so they
usually see this as a tool that they can
believe and they still consume Turkish
coffee a lot a lot of times the people
who are going to do it as other people
who have the time to be able to commit
two hours to a friend and sit down and
they're also saying something about
people don't drink the coffee for the
caffeine that what you said yes what
totally yeah I think really so yeah is
that 100% no one would drink Turkish
coffee because I want to stay awake that
night which I feel like people in the
States and the hardware specifically
we'd do it like to be like oh I need to
waken up today should have a lot of
caffeine and I don't want to find out
later Oh God and I think maybe some
people would find it offensive
if you drag this coffee in a rush to
just keep your stuff awakened because it
is an offense to the tradition of
drinking this coffee and making this
coffee and as we saw earlier it takes
time to make this comment it's not an
instant process and you really need to
spend time no life is going to go
completely
we orange right and no life is going to
go without any problem right so it's
important to highlight opportunities of
growth and opportunities of concern and
really put attention to certain letters
and certain characters and see whether
those letter than those people and those
types of concepts appear in your life
well I can clearly get it now look not
getting stronger on the bottom yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]